- Trump gets a special master.
It's the most beautiful,
special master anyone has ever seen.
It's the most special.
The most wonderful, special
master that has ever existed.
He's not wrong.
People have never seen a
special master like this,
but what does that all mean?
Well, a Florida federal
judge, Aileen Cannon,
has temporarily halted
the criminal investigators
from reviewing the records,
founded MalMar-a-Lago
and ordered the appointment
of a special master to
check the government's work.
However, the judge also allowed
the government's intelligence
damage assessment to continue.
Many lawyers were quick to
condemn the judge's ruling.
- I think the driver on
this from the beginning
was loads of classified
information sitting in Mar-a-Lago.
People say this was unprecedented.
Well, it's also
unprecedented for a president
to take all this classified information
and put 'em in a country club.
- Are they right to be upset?
Well, before we set our hair on fire,
let's look at how we got here
and then consider what
the judge ruled and why.
And of course, why the
DOJ is going to appeal
that order to the 11th
Circuit and what that means.
(majestic music)
Now, all this got off to a strange start
when Trump's lawyers
didn't file this motion in the court
that had created the search
warrant in the first place.
Instead, they created a
new case, a civil case,
and that landed in front of
Federal Judge Aileen Cannon,
who we'll talk about in a moment.
Now, in the DOJs brief in opposition
to an appointment of a special master,
it outlined new details about
the classified documents
that Trump had taken from the White House.
First, it included a
photograph of the materials
displayed on the floor of Mar-a-Lago.
The photo shows five yellow
folders marked top secret,
and a red one labeled secret,
lying on the ground beside
a box of magazine covers.
Now, the photo was
pretty standard procedure
by law enforcement.
They normally document the
things that they have seized.
Now, Trump and his lawyers
were outraged by the photo,
which they say merely shows
that Trump was in possession
of his own records,
but also their response did not address
one of the key claims that Trump
supporters continue to make
that Trump declassified
everything in their possession.
So far, the lawyers have not (chuckles)
bothered to make this
argument in front of a court.
But Donald Trump was very offended
by this photograph for other reasons.
He called up a conservative radio show
to rant about how sloppy the
FBI was with the records.
He claimed he kept them
in a much neater fashion.
- [Trump] But I had confidential documents
spread out all over my floor,
and like a slob.
- Trump's family members
also emphasized the former
president was a neat freak.
Quote, "He's a very neat individual.
He would never scatter documents
around on a floor like that."
But none of this is about
whether Trump is a slobe.
The issue is whether Trump
had possession of documents
that he was not allowed to possess
in a completely unsecured location.
Trump's comments could also
be viewed as an admission
that those records were
not planted by the FBI,
which is contrary some
of the other messaging
that the Trump camp has been doing.
The Justice Department's filing
also pushed back on Trump's claim
that he'd been cooperating
with government all along.
The DOJ said that when they arrived
at Mar-a-Lago on June 3rd,
one of Trump's lawyers
handed over a single
red welled envelope,
double wrapped in tape.
The lawyers said that the records inside
had come from a storage room.
Another lawyer, probably Christina Bobb,
signed a certification letter,
swearing under oath
that a diligence search
had been conducted and that
all the classified materials
on the property had been turned over,
or all the documents that had
been labeled as classified.
Side note, Alina Habba and
Christina Bobb, Trump's lawyers,
have given several interviews
where they potentially
incriminated themselves
as witnesses or targets of
the criminal investigation.
- Sorry to interrupt.
But was there a limited number of people
who had access to that storage room?
It seems like a pretty
important room, right?
Since they've made such a big deal of it
and have the lock on it
- Right.
- and so forth.
So, were there a limited number of people
who could go in and out?
- Yes, absolutely.
- Or have access
to it.
- Truly. Mar-a-Lago...
Certainly. Mar-a-Lago is
secure in and of itself.
Just getting onto the compound is hard.
And then, it was a locked door
and getting backed down into
the basement, there's security.
You can't just walk down there.
Only certain members
of staff can get there.
And then, there's only one key.
- They found these three mundane statutes
espionage and the two others, obstruction.
- Now, Habba told Charlie
Kirk that on May 5th, 2022.
She searched all desks, drawers,
nightstands, dressers, closets, et cetera,
with explicit permission from Trump,
in an effort to track down
documents related to a subpoena
from New York attorney general
Letitia James' investigation
into the Trump organization.
And although the New York investigation
is a separate matter,
Habba placed herself at the
scene of the potential crime.
And when the Justice Department delegation
asked to see the storage room,
a lawyer for Trump
explicitly prohibited them
from opening or looking into
any of the other boxes inside.
The government asserted
that this stopped them
from confirming that no materials
with classification markings
had been left behind.
Investigators then discovered evidence
that there were still classified
documents at Mar-a-Lago.
And this probably came
from witness interviews.
And after further investigation,
the DOJ team said it had reason to believe
the government records
had likely been quote,
"Concealed and removed
from the storage room,"
and that efforts may have
been taken to, quote,
"obstruct the government's investigation."
Then, the government decided
to apply for a search warrant.
In the filing, the government said
that when they went inside Mar-a-Lago,
agents found more than twice the number
of classified documents
that Trump's lawyers
had handed over before
when they allegedly had made
their diligence search back in June,
including three, that were
found not in the storage room,
but in desks in the
form president's office.
Now, the DOJs brief also included
two grand jury subpoenas.
The first subpoena asked Trump
to turn over the documents at Mar-a-Lago.
And the second was for footage
from surveillance cameras.
Mar-a-Lago footage would be used
to track the movement of the
materials within the club.
Now, I'm largely going to skip
over the Trump reply brief
in response to the DOJs opposition.
It's less of a legal document
and more of just a
public relations attempt.
It really doesn't
address any of the things
that the judge wanted them to address.
It fails to rebut any of
the arguments (chuckles)
that the DOJ has put forward.
And similarly, as we covered before,
the judge teed up exactly the issues
that she wanted the Trump team to address,
and they failed to address those issues
in either the moving papers
for the special master
or in the reply brief.
Effectively, their papers
were just placeholders,
just getting something
in front of the judge.
Though as we now know,
that's all they needed to do.
As I alluded to earlier,
the judge has now ruled in Trump's favor
on the motion to appoint a special master.
The order appointing a special master
was issued by District
Court Judge Aileen Cannon,
who, it's important to note,
was nominated by Trump
to the bench in 2020.
Judge Cannon was confirmed by the Senate
by a vote of 56 to 21
just days after Trump lost
the November, 2020 election.
So, first things first,
is it kosher for a judge to
rule on a criminal matter
involving the president
who appointed them?
Well, there's absolutely no
law saying that they can't.
Generally, it's not a conflict of interest
for judges to rule on matters
involving the president
who appointed them.
This happens fairly regularly.
But that typically comes
up in the context of laws
that the president enacts
or executive orders that they issue,
not in actual criminal matters
that concern that particular president.
All right, so with that out of the way,
let's look at what the judge actually did.
The first issue is the
judge's order on Rule 41 (g).
Trump filed a motion seeking the return
of privileged materials and property
under federal rule of
criminal procedure, 41 (g).
That rule allows a person, quote,
"Aggrieved by an unlawful
search and seizure
of property or by the deprivation
of property to move for
the property's return."
Now, since there's no
pending criminal case,
Trump filed a motion as a
plaintiff in a civil case.
That means he was trying to initiate
an action in the pre-indictment stage.
Now, in the case of Richie versus Smith,
the 5th Circuit Court of Appeals
developed a four-part test
to determine whether the government
must return property in
a pre-indictment case.
First, whether the motion
for return of property
accurately alleges the government agents
displayed a callous disregard
for the rights of the plaintiff.
Second, whether the plaintiff
has an individual interest
in and need for the material
whose return he seeks.
Third, whether the plaintiff
would be irreparably injured
by the denial of the
return of the property.
And fourth, whether the
plaintiff has an adequate
remedy at law for the
redress of his grievance.
Now, the rationale of the Richie
case is that the government
should not be allowed to season
retain privileged documents
in a pre-indictment setting.
However, quote, "In order
for an owner of property
to invoke Rule 41 (g), he must show
that he had a possessory interest
in the property seized by the government."
Now, the DOJ had argued
that Trump cannot show
he had a right to the
records that were seized,
citing the Presidential Records Act,
which says that presidential records
are owned by the United States,
not by the former president.
And during oral argument on the motion,
the judge asked Trump's lawyer
to address the second
and third Richie factors.
Lawyer Jim Trusty, Trump's lawyer,
replied that the entire dispute
was akin to an argument
over overdue library books.
Now, the judge described
Trump's motion as quote,
"Somewhat convoluted,"
but concluded that, quote,
"this filing is procedurally permissible
and creates an action in equity."
Though, there has been a lot of pushback
about the court's jurisdiction
in this particular case.
And in assessing the Richie factors,
the judge said that the DOJ
did not display callous
disregard for Trump's rights.
So, the government came out
ahead on the first factor,
but it was all downhill from there.
As to the second factor,
whether Trump has an
individual interest in
and need for the material seized,
the judge said that this
factor cut in Trump's favor
since the DOJ by its own admission,
had seized Trump's medical records,
correspondence related to taxes,
and financial information.
Judge Cannon says that this amounts
to over 500 pages of documents,
however, the government
seized over 11,000 documents,
which means that the subset of documents
that belongs to Trump
amounts to less than 5%
of the record seized under the warrant.
The DOJ argued that the
mixing of these personal items
with other documents
is evidence of a crime
and can have evidentiary
value in and of itself.
If Trump stored his personal records
with classified materials
and post-it notes,
it could suggest something
about his mens rea,
his mental state, for what he was doing
with these classified
or protected documents.
Now, Judge Cannon is a
former federal prosecutor,
and she agreed that the
Justice Department's concern
was valid, but she said that
Trump's interest was stronger.
And the third factor is irreparable harm.
To show irreparable harm,
a plaintiff needs to demonstrate
that there would be no
remedy for the damage
that the government inflicted.
The judge concluded that a special master
was necessary to stop harm
to Trump's reputation.
Leaks to the press could
be harmful to Trump.
And the judge concluded with no analysis
that the government leaked
stories to the press,
although the government
obviously denied this,
and she seemed to ignore the fact
that it was former president Trump,
who was providing almost all
of the information to the press
when these things happened in real time.
Now, Judge Cannon said that Trump
could be irreparably harmed,
because of the stigma of
potential criminal prosecution,
quote, "Frequently, the public
remembers the accusation
and still suspects guilt,
even after an acquittal."
Though as many criminal defense
lawyers have pointed out,
including Renayo Mariotti,
Mark Zaid, and Sara Azari,
all defendants suffer reputational damage
when they are indicted,
not just this former president.
These lawyers also said that
they were looking forward
to citing this case on
behalf of their clients.
And yes, it would be good
for criminal defendants
if they could have a special master
to review evidence seized from them
in the pre-indictment stage,
in all criminal cases.
And they would have a much better chance
of avoiding criminal indictment
if they could identify
the government's witnesses
and knew what the government
was thinking beforehand.
And that's one of the reasons why the DOJ
opposed Trump's motion
for a special master.
But national security
lawyer, Bradley Moss,
thinks that it won't help
most criminal defendants
because the judge wrote this
to help Trump and Trump only.
Now, in her order, Judge Cannon
seems to confirm Moss' conclusion
that the rules are different
in this particular case,
quote, "As a function of
plaintiff's former position
as president of the United States,
the stigma associated
with the subject seizure
is in a league of its own."
And Judge Cannon came
up with another reason
why Trump might suffer
irreparable harm, quote,
"A future indictment based
to any degree on property
that ought to be returned, would
result in reputational harm
of a decidedly different
order of magnitude."
Of course we aren't there yet.
Trump has not been indicted,
much less indicted because
of personal property
that the FBI had no right to seize.
And as many have pointed out, often,
you are allowed to seize documents
that are intermingled with the documents
that are explicitly mentioned
in a search warrant.
But the judge suggests that Trump
wouldn't have any remedy or any defense
if he was indicted based on material
the government should not have seized.
But that's incorrect.
If Trump is indicted using evidence
that the government should not have taken,
his lawyers would file a motion
to suppress the evidence.
But Judge Cannon heads this off
and argues that a special master
can prevent this from happening
by checking the government's
work in the first place.
Now, all of this seems to contradict
the judge's same decision
to allow the intelligence
community through the ODNI
to continue its review of the evidence
while the criminal
investigation has to stop.
Here, the ODNI is doing
its damage assessment
to find out who had access
to the sensitive
information in the documents
and whether national security
interests were compromised.
And I suppose someone could argue
that the criminal investigation
into Trump's records
would harm his reputation
while the intelligence community
investigation would not.
But that seems incredibly dubious,
not to mention it's all part
of the same executive branch,
which many have argued, as
a unitary executive branch.
And on top of that,
the intelligence review
could lead to further criminal charges.
Moreover, some people
have already concluded
that Trump put human
intelligence sources at risk.
That conclusion, if it's mistaken,
would seem to be just
as serious as the stigma
that attaches to a criminal
investigation itself.
Now, the DOJ filed an extensive brief
explaining how its filter
team separates personal items
and attorney client privileged records
from everything else that the DOJ sees.
The judge was unmoved by
their arguments however.
She held that Trump met
the four Richie factors.
The judge said that
rating the ex-president
without a third party reviewer
just doesn't look good.
Quote, "The government's argument
that another round of initial screening
is unnecessary also disregards the value
added by an outside reviewer in terms of,
at a minimum, the appearance of fairness.
Even if the DOJ filter review teams
often pass procedural muster,
they're not always perceived
to be as impartial as special masters."
And that takes us to the judge's analysis
of the executive privilege issue,
which is to put it mildly, convoluted.
Judge Cannon says the
government made a mistake
by not screening the records
for executive privilege.
Now, this overlooks the
fact that Justice Department
is part of the executive branch
and that President Biden holds
the executive privilege now
and has already delegated
his authority to NARA,
which says none of these documents
can be protected by Trump
under the guise of executive privilege.
But this order hints that
this is really dispute
between former president Trump
and current president Biden.
The Supreme Court's president says
that executive privilege almost
under every circumstance,
stays with the office of
the current president.
It's theoretically possible
under the Nixon versus GSA case
for a former president to have
some tiny sliver of executive privilege,
but that's never happened so far
and the circumstances at which
that could theoretically happen
are extremely circumscribed.
But the judge says that a special master
must review all the government records
to determine if Trump can
raise executive privilege
to shield these records.
But so far, the judge has
only raised this issue.
We don't know what procedures,
if any of the special master
will have to follow when one is appointed.
So, let's talk about what it means
to appoint a special master.
Normally, a special master
would help the court
sift through materials
that may be subject to
attorney-client privilege.
Now, someone is going
to screen these records
for attorney-client privilege
and presumably, executive privilege.
But that's sort of up in the air.
The federal courts
haven't developed case law
about when an ex-president can
assert executive privilege.
So, the special master is
not gonna have any guidance
based on the case law itself.
But presumably, we'll get
more guidance from the court
when it issues its final order,
actually appointing the special master.
And there is another complication
that goes unaddressed by the judge.
Here, the PRA requires a dispute
over presidential records
to be handled in the US district
court in Washington, DC.
44 USC section 2204 states, quote,
"The United States district court
for the district of Columbia
shall have jurisdiction
over any action initiated
by the former president,
asserting that a determination
made by the archivist violates
the former president's
constitutional rights or privileges."
Here, Judge Cannon, in her order,
said she recognizes that
this is the law of the PRA,
but she doesn't say how the
special master's appointment
can be squared with Section 2204.
If she admits that Section 2204 applies,
then why would a special master appointed
in the Southern District
of Florida have any power?
Why does her particular civil court case
have any power in the
Southern District of Florida?
So, what happens next?
Well, now, the parties
must meet and confer
about who might serve as a special master.
Ideally, they would
agree on a list of names,
but that's almost certainly
not going to happen here.
Keep in mind that this order
only applies to evidence
seized on August 8th.
It actually doesn't apply to
an earlier subset of documents
that Trump sent to NARA
or the boxes of records
that his lawyers gave to the
New York City DA, Alvin Bragg.
And while many attorneys
have rightfully criticized
Judge Cannon's order here,
we'll really get a window
into whether she's just
trying to bend over backwards
to provide fairness to a former president
in a politically charged atmosphere,
or whether she's in the bag for Trump
based on who she appoints
as the special master.
And on Thursday, the Department of Justice
officially filed a notice
of appeal with Judge Cannon
and a motion for partial stay of her order
regarding the special
master pending that appeal.
Now, the notice of appeal
is just a placeholder.
It's just a paragraph that
you file with the court
that says they will appeal
the September 5th special
master order and the injunction,
but the motion for partial
stay has more detail.
The government, quote,
"Seeks to stay to the
extent that the order
enjoins the further review
and use for criminal
investigative purposes of records,
bearing classification markings
that were recovered pursuant
to a court authorized search warrant,
and requires the government
to disclose those classified records
to a special master for review."
Now, the DOJ says that it disagrees
with the court's decision
to appoint a special master
over the materials,
but it's only seeking an immediate relief
over a subset of those records,
the ones marked classified,
because those aspects of the order
will cause the most
immediate and serious harms
to the government and the public.
The classified records, a discrete set
of just over 100 documents,
have already been segregated
from the other seized records,
and are being maintained separately.
Now, the Department of Justice
argues the classified records
are also not personal to the plaintiff,
former president Trump,
and would not reveal any
sensitive personal information.
The Justice Department took issue
with the judge's conclusion
that as of right now,
it is impossible to determine
which records Trump might own,
saying that the classified
government records,
"Are easily identifiable
by their markings,
are already segregated from
the other seized records
and do not include personal records
or potentially privileged communications
with his personal attorneys."
In other words, the DOJ has
already done his review.
The government disagreed, as expected,
with the judge's interpretation
of executive privilege
and the Nixon versus GSA case.
And the DOJ has a bone
to pick with Judge Cannon
over her reliance on a
concurrence by Justice Kavanaugh
in the case of Trump versus Thompson.
The DOJ argued, quote,
"Thompson involved a claim
of executive privilege
by a plaintiff as to records
sought by a congressional committee,
which means that he wanted
to stop dissemination
of the privileged materials
outside of the executive branch."
And that makes a little bit of sense
in the possible theoretical places
where a former president could
exert executive privilege,
it would probably be
against a third party,
not the executive branch itself.
And the DOJ argued that, quote,
"Neither the Supreme Court's opinion
and Kavanaugh's concurring statement,
concluded that an ex-president
can successfully assert
executive privilege
to prevent the executive branch itself
from reviewing and using its own records."
The DOJ also argued it
didn't make any sense
that part of the executive branch
could continue its review
and part of the executive
branch could not.
But this appeal is a risky move.
It could lead to a delay
that could take longer
than complying with a
special master procedures.
And they could also lose the appeal
because the 11th Circuit
is gonna 11th Circuit
and generate unfavorable precedent.
And in a minute order,
the court asked both parties
to respond to the DOJs motion
and it gave Trump until September
12th to file his response.
Now, some see this as the
beginning of the judge
walking back from her extreme position
before getting hammered on appeal,
but she may also just be
crossing T's and dotting I's.
But you'll be able to read all
about Trump's circumvention
of all rational laws in
today's sponsor, Morning Brew,
because that's my favorite way
to catch up with pop culture and the news.
I've actually been subscribed
to Morning Brew for forever.
It's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters,
and I'm really thrilled to tell you why.
Because Morning Brew, if
you didn't already know,
it's a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday.
It gets you up to speed on business,
finance, tech and law
in just five minutes.
It provides a fantastic quick summary
of the most important issues,
all while being witty,
irreverentm informative, and fun.
And did I mention it's completely free?
This week, I read all about
the passing of the Queen,
the UK's new Prime Minister,
NASA's new space launch Artemis,
Missouri bringing back
spanking to its schools,
and someone who sailed 40
miles in an 861-pound pumpkin.
It's basically exactly the mix of news
that I'm actually interested in
and the stuff that I'd even
know I wanted to know about.
And it's all written in a hilarious style.
Morning Brew is one of the few emails
that I actually open every single day.
So, LegalEagle, this one
is a complete no brainer.
Morning Brew is completely free
and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe.
Just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description to
get a Morning Brew for free.
And not only will you get a newsletter
that you'll actually read,
you'll actually help out this channel too.
So, click on the link below to
get Morning Brew right away.
And after that, click
on this link over here
for more LegalEagle or
I'll see you in court.